hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Denby
and I'm your driver on this journey last
weekend was actually a pretty exciting
time for me to tournaments that I was
playing in just wrapped up the st. Louis
district championship was a weekend
tournament that happened just last
weekends as well as the monthly Knights
tournament the final round for September
was on Tuesday and actually I was
fortunate enough to have a pretty good
performance in both of those tournaments
and it has pushed me over 2,200 so I'm
now a national master yep thank you
thank you very much so tonight I thought
I would go over some of those games from
both of these tournaments that got me to
this this new heights in my chess career
if you'll indulge a little little uh you
know self-praise here this first game
was pretty interesting this was the
first round of the st. Louis district
championships I was paired against the
terrifying
Alex fear but it turns out he was too
afraid of me because I played one d4 and
he was not there he did not show up for
the game so my tournament started off
very strong with a forfeit win because
the Grandmaster was so afraid of me that
he flew out of the city two days before
the tournament before he even knew he
was gonna play me you just had to get
out of there
yeah he knew he knew I was on the hunt
for the title so yeah Alex fear that
game never happens i won by forfeit
after that Mike comer tournament
director found it fitting to pair me up
against international master Robbie
kevlars feely and I had the white pieces
once again since the first game never
really happens and I wanted to go
through this one because there's a lot
of interesting things about it you might
know of the exchange Slav which is the
opening that I played Slav is d4 d5 c4
c6 and the exchanges with C takes d5 C
takes d5 so how many of you are familiar
with this opening Jason knows it yeah so
do you know what kind of reputation it
has so it's kind of got a reputation for
being very boring very symmetrical it's
what you play when you're not really
pressing for an advantage that's the
reputation it has yeah that you're
looking for a draw but that's actually
not how the game has to go no matter
what opening you're playing if both
players are willing to go for some
imbalances you can find ways to make the
game interesting and so despite this
simple position we actually got a quite
imbalanced game and so we'll take a look
at that I start with Bishop f4 and after
knight c6 White's next move is pretty
important actually it'd be pretty
natural to play a move like Knight c3
kind of mirroring black hitting the
center and going for b5
yes so I'm curious do any of you know
the problem with Knight c3 it's
something really immediate that black
can do to kind of strike back and show
white how he's been playing a little bit
nonchalantly already in the first few
moves
so e5 what if I captured
well don't give up yet because II five
is actually the best move for black here
and while it is upon sacrifice it's a
very good pun sacrifice for black
actually and it's all because of this
next move that is the follow-up yeah so
this this pawn can advance forward to d4
yeah and yeah and this Knight is
actually this sides very awkwardly
placed you can put it on e4 but so this
is actually not really ideal for white
so because of this line which thankfully
I knew about I played this move III so
now of course the the same line doesn't
work if e5 simply D takes e5 and if d4 I
can just take this pawn off the board
yeah and and there's no no knight on c3
yet so just a little opening nuance
there so III Knight f6 now both players
just develop normally I do develop my
bishop before either of my knight is
here and the reason for that is I'm
aiming to make my opponent's development
a little less natural if I play move
like Knight c3 sometimes black has this
option to just bring this bishop to a
natural square so Bishop d3
is aimed at preventing that my opponent
decided to not lock in as Bishop here
this is playable for black but it kind
of gives us white an edge I think in
some lines
so yet this is this bishops usually the
problem bishop yeah so in this case
black decided to bring it out to g4
pretty early on and now how would you
respond to this if you were white when
you develop the knight to f3 to e2 would
you push the pawn forward to hit the
bishop or would you move the Queen out
of the way there's a lot of options here
for white I'm curious which one you you
guys think would be a the best push the
pawn forward and why is that yeah so
you're hitting the black bishop you
force the bishop to move away and you're
kind of gaining time by doing that right
you get to play this move kind of for
free because your opponent has to move
the bishop again are there any downsides
to f3 though
yeah all of a sudden this III pun looks
a little bit loose and while it's easy
to say you know okay it's it has less
defense than before it's not so clear
how black can make use of it
f3 is actually totally fine move here
but it is a little more committal than
some of the other choices yet Queen B 3
is a very nice option you can you know
hit this Punk
perhaps black might have to respond with
something like Queen b6 or maybe the
more natural Queen d7 just defending the
pawn laterally and preparing to finish
development so both of those moves are
fine but they weren't the move that I
chose and I'll talk a little bit later
on about why committing to f3 early on
isn't always the best idea so nobody
said Knight f3 which i think is good you
don't really want a self pin like this
you don't wanna put yourself in this pin
but I chose option number 492 so while I
am still pins now I always have this
option of playing f3 in removing this
Bishop so I'm just choosing you know the
most flexible lines black plays a six I
develop my Knights and black plays
Bishop d6 so either a couple options
here
black is threatening to take this bishop
but it's not really actually a huge
threat for example say I play Queen d2
if he takes and I take
yeah it's true that this deep pond gets
a little bit more weak but like you're
about to say I do have a very nice lock
or control over the e5 square so this
would be fine but I was just playing
simply playing naturally so I just
captured this Bishop the Queen captures
I Castle black castles I bring a rook to
the open file and my opponent brings the
rook to the open file and I would say
this is the first position where I
really kind of sat down it and had a
long think and so the reason for that is
I've developed my pieces to very natural
squares I've kind of completed
development and now it's time to figure
out how can I improve my pieces how can
I form a plan and so there are a couple
of different plans so I can go for here
and it's all about choosing the one that
you think is best
so first let's try to come up with some
ideas so what are some ideas you might
have for white in this position how do
you either improve your pieces or even
go for a pawn break or go for some
positional edge any ideas
okay you can unpin the night was
something like Queen B 3 maybe Queen d2
as well that those would be improving
moves I suppose any other ideas for
white just anything it doesn't have to
be correct it doesn't have to be the
best plan just ideas to be thinking
about yeah maybe now is the time to
commit to f3 forcing this bishop away
and now we have ideas of playing Eve for
you yeah so f3 also has this advantage
of breaking this pin and controlling a
little bit to the center but there was a
reason I didn't like f3 here but before
I talk about those specifics let's find
some more ideas for white some natural
ideas yeah the Queen so yeah Knight b5
is another very natural move it hits
this Queen the Queen would have to move
away but then all of a sudden what is my
knight really really accomplishing on
this square and it's a little tough to
decipher yeah yeah so there is however a
knight maneuver in this position that's
very common for white so I'm curious if
you guys can can find that Knight
maneuver
yeah Jason yeah
Knight f4 to c5 is another very common
maneuver you can imagine let's say
Knight a for black just naturally starts
to double rooks I can bring this Knight
to c5 and I'm putting some pressure on
the queenside and to move like b6 would
kick the night out but it's not without
downsides the sudden you see this Knight
becomes a little bit more loose the
b-pawn no longer defends it there's
things like the a6 square that what
black has to worry about whether a
bishop or a knight might land there and
this would cause some permanent
weaknesses in the black camp so these
are a lot of the ideas I have moving
around in my head I want to maybe
improve this Knight from a four to c5 I
maybe want to play f3 just an example of
another idea maybe I want to move my
queen off the back rank and double my
rooks there are a lot of ways I can try
to improve the position however I
thought that all of these moves had some
downsides so let's see if we can come up
with you know the downsides how black
might respond to some of these plans
so with f3 let's say Bishop h5 and I
just play I don't know some improving
move here like Queen d2 now that I've
committed to f3 what ideas for black
might become a bit stronger there's one
idea in particular
any ideas for black hair
yes something like night before is
definitely an idea to look out for but
dropping the bishop back to be one
actually isn't so bad this is still a
very relevant diagonal for the bishop to
be on and similar to night be five and
the fact that eventually White's gonna
get this time back by kicking the night
away so what do we say the weakness of
f3 was what pawn did it weaken
yeah weaken the e3 pawn so is there any
way for black to open it up in such a
way that he has access to this new
weakness yeah pawn to e5 yeah it'd be
very natural for me to take this pawn
and after something like either Queen
takes or even Queen takes all all of a
sudden black has access to my weakness
and while he's made a weakness himself
it's gonna be a lot more double-edged
you can imagine if this pawn were on f2
this would just be better for white than
this position so if you play f3 you're
kind of committing to this long-term
weakness if you're allowing black to
play e5 and if you're playing Knight oh
for sure so in if you play Knight f4
you're doing a similar thing this knight
on c3 was doing a nice job of
controlling the center and now that
you've moved it away you can imagine
that these ideas still get a little bit
stronger because now I don't have this
nice Knight adding a little bit of
pressure to Black's pawn and all of a
sudden this e5 square is no longer an
outpost so I was thinking here about all
these ideas and I thought hmm it seems
like if I commit to anything and gives
my opponent something to do and then I
realized that the pawn structure is
symmetrical and the piece placements are
not all together all that different so I
realized my opponent probably has a lot
of the same problems that I do so what I
did was kind of a waiting move but also
it had a purpose and improved my
and this is the type of position where
that can be really powerful where you
don't want to commit to anything just
yet and you kind of want to wait and see
what your opponent does did you have a
question yeah rookie one is a great
waiting move in my case I made a move
that actually kind of forces my
opponents hand if you wanted to just
make some improving move something like
we need to I think would be ok you are
stepping into some ideas with 94
eventually something like rookie 1 would
also be fun even something like Bishop
be won preemptively stepping out of
night before but the move I made was
kind of forcing my opponents hand
I played a 3 here so let's say black
does nothing here let's say black tries
to play it a little bit more slowly h6
would be a bad move though let's say I
don't know perhaps Knight d7 Musa move
what was a the idea of a 3 what is y
going to do now
yeah it's definitely related to this c5
square
yeah so not quite a big problem with
night a four and was that after E 5 if
this D pawn moves I really don't have
any backup on the the c5 square yeah
b4 was my idea if my opponent didn't do
much I was gonna play b4 now I have
ideas of routing this night and the
stronghold is a little bit more solid on
c5 I also have ideas of expanding even
further and shaking loose some of the
black pieces yeah but like we said
earlier if he does commit to something
like b6 these white squares are a lot
weaker than they used to be and I can
invade with my bishop at any moment so
that was my idea and my opponent played
the most testing way a3 was not without
its downsides it does weaken my own
light squares a little bit so my
opponent tried to take advantage of it
with Knight a5 and here a lot of the
same problems that I had with playing
Knight a for myself because this is for
my opponent with Knight a5 the fact is
you're really moving a piece from the
center of the board to the side of the
board and when you see something like
this happen that's when you really want
to be looking out for ideas in the
center so here I came up with a nice
tactical line where I played be for the
night comes to c4 and after Knight b5
the Queen moves away and I get to take
this night off of c4 giving away my very
powerful Bishop but for a good reason
this forces the pawn to move away from
the center if you were to capture with
the rook
I would capture again and the pawn would
in fact move away from the center in the
game actually I believe I played f3
first see a 95 I started with f3 Bishop
h5 and then I went in for this line with
the same ideas the Queen came to e7
yeah and this Bishop is actually looking
a little bit forlorn over here on the
side of the board it's not really
contributing so after it takes on c4 and
takes on c4 what do you guys think the
the best move is here for white keep in
mind we just moved our opponent's pieces
away from the center his pawn away from
the center so that's probably where we
should be playing so what move comes to
mind immediately yeah simply e4 the
smooth has a few purposes it's getting
ready to respond with a move like 'if
I've it was simply something like d5
yeah
d5 would might be good also I could just
simply take this pawn and the main point
is that it's really locking this Bishop
out of the game and this is gonna be a
huge problem for my opponent in the game
my opponent responded with a6 pretty
quickly forcing this knight back to c3
he might have been worried about ideas
of this Knight coming to d6 eventually
which is understandable and then he
played Knight d7 and so I have a few
options here first of all what is 97
kind of telegraphing what does he want
to do next there's a few ideas going on
this one yes so maybe he's eyeing up
some ePHI of ideas but I don't think
that was the main point so I'll give you
a hit my opponents a very strong player
and he wanted to improve his worst piece
so how is 97 helping to improve this
bishop it's a little bit subtle yeah
yeah he wants to move this F pawn this
Knight was in the way and so he's moving
it out of the way so this F pawn can
move now f5 might be a little bit too
much if you let's say I play a simple
move like Queen d2 if f5 I might respond
with E 5 and permanently lock these
pawns and kind of an unfortunate
structure and this Bishop might not find
daylight but in the game I actually did
play Queen d2 and he played f6 so my
question for you is he's getting ready
to improve this bishop and at the moment
I have the option to take it off the
board so how could I take it how can I
trade this Bishop off for a knight very
easily not really a trick or anything
just the bishop has no squares yeah
Knight f4 hits this Bishop hits it's
only retreat square I could trade this
Bishop off if I really wanted to so my
next question is do you think that's a
good idea for white in this position
yeah so the bishops bad the thing is
this Knights not really great either
though so the question is which piece do
you think is gonna be more valuable
eventually do you think after f6 and
Bishop f7 this Bishop has a better
future than this Knight or do you think
we can find some good squares some good
outposts to put this night on this is
really the question to be asking which
piece has the better future and so what
do you think
the night okay so if you say the night
you have to have some kind of eventual
plan for it so what's your plan for the
night what are you going to do with it
to g3 and then what do you want to do
from there
yeah okay so from g3 first of all you're
hitting the bishop coercing the bishop
to kind of an uncomfortable square on g6
and then from there you have to find the
future for the night and the future
really less rests with the pawn brakes I
think 93 would have been a really great
move here I actually played it on the
next turn which might be slightly worse
but I think it's also good for white
first I played Queen d2 with the idea
that after Knight g3 my opponent might
play Queen g5 and be taking away some
dark squares for myself so I started
with Queen d2 f6 was played like I said
improving the bishop
right so I take advantage of these dark
squares and then kick this bishop away
and the bishop drops back to f7 so now
this Knight is looking at the center
these two squares this Knight is looking
at these two squares but I need some way
to shake loose these these pawns and so
there are a few ways I can do that what
are a few ideas for some pawn breaks
that'll kind of open up the center give
my Knights some more options so yeah
rook e1 is a great great way to start
really either rook but eventually which
pawn break do you want to play there let
me just give you some options so yeah at
first I played f4 and now let's say my
opponent and pastor something would you
want to play F v e5 or d5 here you
really have three options and it's not
so clear which one is the best
'if I've it's okay if you play e5 how do
you expect your opponent to respond pawn
takes or f5 pawn takes how do you want
to take back
f-pawn ticks okay now the pawn breaks
that kind of happens do your Knights
have squares now don't have a future
what's your plan for the Knights yeah I
think this would be great for white this
is actually the idea that I kind of had
in mind you do have to look out for
other role other relevant lines though
for example if f5 now how do you shake
loose these pawns how do you get your
Knights to have some active play
that's exactly right d5 would be the
threat here and if black were to capture
of course now this weakens this f-pawn
and beginning to our our lovely score on
d6 and if black were to ignore it he
would be facing quite a lot of problems
one of which is d6 yeah and our Knights
would still have good squares for
example this d4 square it's both of
blacks weaknesses here so this was my
big plan so once again my opponent is a
very strong player he's not going to be
rolled over quite so easily so he came
up with active counter play and this is
exactly what you should do if you think
your opponent is like on the brink of
really breaking through really making
his plans work you need to find active
counter play somewhere else on the board
so where is that other spot on the board
for black to kind of make counter play
activate his own pieces I'll give you a
hint it's not in the center that's where
I want to play yeah something like a f5
could shake loose these pawns and all of
a sudden yet the black pieces are kind
of invading so in the game my opponents
started with rook da just placing this
rook opposite the Queen I decided to
move my queen to e3 looking back maybe I
should have been a bit more aware of the
Queen side and rather than moving my
queen away from it just brought in more
pieces into the center not worried so
much about the rug did you have a
question
yeah this would be possible as well the
problem I thought was that here he can
actually play b5 and the point of this
trick is kind of revealed now there are
some tactical tactical lines that take
advantage of this yeah these are
actually exactly the ideas I was looking
at and so I decided I would just move my
queen out of the pin and then these
ideas would be renewed but perhaps it
was a little bit too nonchalant for me
to kind of lackadaisical to expect that
my opponent would let me do all these
things when instead he's breaking
immediately with a 5 as he should
however I wasn't totally unprepared for
this break I did have some idea of what
I was going to do I started with rook b1
making sure I get some activity as well
on the open B file he captures and now
quick question
should I take back with the pawn or the
rook which one gets my pieces more
activity yeah definitely the rook I want
my own open file if my opponent gets
this one I want this one I want
something in return
yeah and I haven't taken a look at this
I thought things were going still pretty
well for me but then my opponent played
a move I did not really expect but it
wasn't the most threatening move it was
actually Knight be 8 he saw that after
rook b7 there would be that
uncomfortable pin and so he wanted to
avoid that I played very naturally I get
my last piece into a you know some
active play on this B file with rook F
b1 my opponent now reroutes this Knight
to a more natural square my take on b7
and he takes on a3 and so uh now white
actually has another really important
choice black has crashed through on the
Queen's side but you have you know kind
of crash through on the B file as well
so you both have activity over here
currently black has a threat that threat
is this pawn is attacked twice and only
defended once
so as white would you want to break
through in the center immediately with a
move like d5 or would you want to play
it take it a little bit more slowly get
this Knight back to a more reasonable
Square and just defend your pawn is it
time to break through now or is it time
to kind of pull it back and wait okay so
you want to play ninety two and then you
want to play it ticket a little bit more
slowly so what would you do after let's
say black just improves his Knight with
something like ninety five heading for
heading for b3
also keep an eye on your rook
yeah it's kind of a tough question but
White has a few options here actually
you can just retreat the rook to a
square on the B file maybe you can also
get away with putting the strip on c7
and just take the game a little bit more
slowly your opponent might want to get
rid of this active rook and you can
imagine you know some position like this
where you still have pressure here your
opponent still is pressure with the
Queen and eventually you're going to
break through in the center yeah I think
both ways of playing we're actually fine
I chose to play a little bit more
immediately because I felt like with my
opponents Queen really kind of diverted
over to the Queen side like this now the
time was right for me to play in the
center which is fine for white but it's
not crushing or anything I think the
computer actually likes 92 a bit better
but I played e5 right away he captures I
capture it's important to note you can't
actually win this pawn because there is
some slight tactics going on if Knight
takes I'm not hanging my queen because
the knight defends it and if rook takes
there's this nice Queen e6 check winning
the rook
so instead my opponent plays the very
natural rook e8 kind of shaking loose my
queen from this nice square rise this
diagonal I play Queen d2 giving my upon
some support and now Knight a5 and at
this point I spent quite a lot of my
time actually because I wasn't sure if I
could really get away with York c7 in
the end I decided I could and played it
it actually turns out that Black has a
pretty nice position here after I
removed like Knight b3 it would have
been better for me to stay a little bit
more solid bring this rook to b5 where
it's nice and defended all my pieces are
kind of working together
so you gotta look out for the Queen
first and then after move like queen bee
to there's actually some uncomfortable
ideas here for black one of them is
rookie one check trying to remove the
defender of my queen another one might
just be like queen bee for defending
this pawn and my pieces just look a
little bit silly so that's what blacks
should have done instead black played
the lines that I was calculating with
this move Queen d6
trying to immediately point out that my
rook is a little bit stuck on c7 I have
calculated out that night b5 would be
okay for me there are a lot of lines
that I was thinking about with black
taking this pawn and I decided you know
they didn't look winning for me but I
thought I got enough play for them but
my opponent must have agreed with me
because instead of taking like Queen b6
check between F to interrupt b8 from
here my play was actually pretty forced
I didn't have to do a whole lot of
thinking which is something nice about
you know calculating out a long line and
then seeing it appear on the board if
you don't have a lot of options you just
play the moose so I have a lot of
problems here my knight is pinned to my
rook he might be threatening to actually
take this rook and then take on b1 so to
solve those problems I have to trade off
these Queens so I do now all of a sudden
I realize huh my pawn is actually pretty
difficult to defend here my opponent is
just gonna take it if I don't do
anything if I try to defend with Knight
c3 you can actually take on b1 and then
take the pawn if I try to defend some
other way with leg rip d7 this rook
looks pretty awkward here and these
ideas might might start becoming a
reality but then I remembered thank God
pawns can legally move in chess so I
moved my part yeah so this I think was
the only way to defend so it's what I
played my opponent once again threatened
to capture my pawn of course now the
idea is still in this pin on the rook
and so I played the only move to defense
which is Knight f5 yeah he played Bishop
g6 trying to pin both of my Knights but
thankfully as you said I have this check
and I just take this Bishop off the
board and now for the second time I
thought wow it's really tough to defend
this pawn thankfully it can move again
so I come to d7 yeah
here why didn't I play d7 yeah it was
possible I think probably my opponent
would play Bishop e6 Tessier this is a
good point I think there might be knight
c6 these lends get a little bit
complicated and now it's gonna be tough
for me to actually defend this pawn
oh and wait now I actually have to work
c8 captures as possible and this Bishop
defense but yeah these were lines that I
had to calculate so I decided I had to
get rid of this Bishop before pushing
the pawn to d7 he has like a question
and so we got to this position and here
I actually expected the game to end in a
draw fairly quickly I thought the only
really reasonable move for my opponent
was to try to get rid of this rook with
rook c6 I thought I would have to take
it and after captures I would play rook
c1 you would take here I would take here
and we would have three pawns versus
three on the Kings side and we would
agree to a draw
yeah maybe you know I can try to win a
pond or something but actually in a
position like that three ponds versus
two even would still likely be a jaw
it's tough to win when all the pawns are
in the same side of the board like that
instead though my opponent surprised me
with King e7 I did not expect this move
because now after rook e1 yep the only
move that makes sense is rookie six
otherwise you would just move the King
back to where it came from and now I
just play rook d1 and now I have this
extra support from my pawn so now my
opponent tried to play rook c6 and I
have the same option as last time of
taking and playing rook c1 and against
an international master would you dear
class members go for the draw or would
you keep trying to play for a win here
go for the draw probably well say okay
not an international masters say someone
300 points higher rated than you play
for the win
so you should always play for the win
here and the reason is even if you lose
you're gonna learn more about chess if
you lose this position than if you
agreed to a draw here it's easy to get
caught up with saying okay I want to
gain rating points I do that by you know
getting better results if I have a draw
in hand and sometimes I lose this game
then I should take the draw but the the
myth of that is actually where that
logic breaks down is the best way to
gain rating points is to get better at
chess and you can't get better at chess
if you don't play these types of
positions out so I declined what was
essentially an offer of drawing the game
and I played her case seven instead
playing for a win so the night is
attacked the knight must move to b3 and
now we had a thirty second increment to
gain some time I thought I'll give this
check again I expected rookie six and
then I was going to repeat and take
another look at my options possibly even
there are some ideas of capturing here
but I don't think they work here but my
opponent surprised me again and played
King f7 I think my opponent really did
not
to draw me because I was much lower
rated than so king f7 was played and now
there is actually a line that I
immediately saw and thought was like
winning for me and I was like freaking
out it's like I thought I was winning so
the question is when you think you're
winning this is an obvious answer
I won't even phrase that as a question
when you think you're winning you should
spend all of your time if you think you
see a line that just immediately wins
the game that's the moment when you sit
there you make sure you use all the time
available to you because if you're right
you don't need the time and if you're
wrong then you better notice so the line
I thought that I saw was rook e8 rook
takes e8 and then of course what would
the winning move for white be in this
position does anybody see it yeah D 8
equals Queen not taking the rook but
queening with check and white would be
up a queen however black has a much
better move here can actually take this
pawn and after takes takes I actually
have very decent chances to lose this
game so just a side note there if you
think you see a line that just wins the
game you really got to slow down make
sure you're absolutely certain before
you take on any chances thankfully I
took my time I noticed that my line
didn't really work it helps that I can
trust my opponent a little bit not to
hang things like this because he's such
a strong player and I came up with a
better move which was Rick c7 so now if
my opponent takes actually have a very
tricky idea of not taking the rook back
but playing Knight d6 rook e8 and takes
and this pawn will actually end up
waiting
so my opponent doesn't play like this
instead plays rook g6 I come back to d1
and now with the added bonus that rook
c6 from my opponent is no longer
available because this and I have stuck
on b3 so my opponent brings the knight
back to a5 very naturally I improve my
night with these two checks and here
white is actually winning the game white
is completely winning here but I did not
find the winning line unfortunately and
it's actually quite complicated but I'll
let you guys give it a shot try to
figure out what's winning to give you a
little hint I'll show you what I played
and the reason it doesn't win
I played rook d5 and thought this was
actually winning for me but
unfortunately there is this nice move
rook c6 from my opponent which forces
all the pieces off the board
he doesn't defend this Knight but rather
forces my pieces onto uncomfortable
squares I had to take and after tix
Knight b6 Knight b8 we agreed to a draw
I'm gonna take this guy he's gonna take
this guy then the game's gonna end so I
tried rook d5 which does not win due to
rook c6 so what do you guys think oh I
can try instead
rook d6 is interesting I think though
well I could just trade and after King
II 798 King e6 this pawn is gonna fall
off the board unless you defend it but
I'm not sure I see the win here for from
for white
what are we looking at so yeah this
actually loses the pond huh
it's kind of similar to rookie 8 line
it's easy to think this sort can't move
up once you attack it because the the
King spent so much time on the eighth
rank but yeah this option is nice for
black so yet not quite rook d6 the
answer is actually something I probably
would have never found over the board is
to take things slowly which you wouldn't
expect here after this simple move
Knight a7 there's actually no way for
black to create any threads here once I
control the c6 square like this the rook
and the knight are both kind of barred
from going to the c6 square there's no
real way for him to threaten to take
this pawn and my rooks are both kind of
unassailable the only way he could try
to trade rooks for example is to play
something like rook d6 of course this
falls tonight c8 so there's really no
way for black to untangle as pieces
after Knight a7 and then yeah believe it
or not the way to win is just bring the
King up push the pawns forward get some
extra space and then in the ends black
is going to be in some sort of zooms
along where he can't move his pieces
I was very short on time and I was I was
never gonna find someone yeah it's it's
pretty high-class stuff that I was
missing so I was happy with rook d5 and
here we agreed to a draw
yeah it's actually quite an interesting
endgame all right we're running a little
bit short on time here
Ryan do you mind if I go a few minutes
over we got started a few minutes late
all right so so this was I think the the
best game that I had played over the
weekends after the weekend and though
there is still one more obstacle in my
path before I could gain the national
master title that obstacle is here with
us tonight in the form of Ryan Dearing
and I wanted to go over this final game
that I had to just not lose in order to
get the title so this was in the Knights
on Tuesday so in this final battle I had
a pretty good idea of what my opponent
played he normally plays something in
some order we get to the Queens gambit
declined and so I'd been doing a bit of
work you know taking the game pretty
seriously I was planning to play the
exchange in some wine like this my
opponent however expected that I would
do all this work and rather than doing
work in the line himself he chose to
surprise me
with doing work in an unorthodox line
with one c5 from black so sitting at the
board in your frame of mind what do you
do when your opponent does something
unorthodox something you don't expect
how should you play yeah Jason sure well
here's the thing I don't have
preparation in this line either believe
oh man you do okay you're ahead of me
so yeah the answer is both of you are
kind of right you just play what you
think are the best chess moves the most
principled chess moves you don't really
make any compromises if you make good
moves in the opening you're not going to
be worse
no matter how much preparation they've
done if you just make good solid moves
then your positions gonna be fine
that's what I did yeah if you're
especially worried you could play
something even more solid like c3 III 9
f3 but I thought the best move in the
position is d5 that's what I'm going to
play my opponent played Knight f6
yeah so Knight f6 I did have some
knowledge about the opening I knew that
a normal benoni Asst white spawn was
already on c4 after something like e six
Knight c3 takes takes you use this C
pawn to take back on d5 but I knew that
a lot of times in the Benoni let's say
in this line yeah after c5 Knight f6
we're gonna get Benoni style positions
and I know this so I know in this line
sometimes this d3 square actually ends
up a bit weak this a pawn moves and you
have some problems with stuff like c4
and I come into e5 and attacking d3 and
I know for this reason it was actually
advantageous to have this pawn on c2 it
controls some of these weak squares so I
just play Knight c3 after d6 I take the
center with E for g6 and I just play
normal developing moves I play Bishop e2
I don't really want my opponent to pin
my knight so I developed the bishop
first Bishop e2 Bishop g7 Knight f3
Bishop g4 and now Knight is actually
more valuable than the bishop in these
positions because it controls these key
dark squares so I play Knight d2 we
trade the pieces in my opponent castles
and I Castle and so believe it or not
despite walking into what seemed to be
my opponent's preparation I just played
solid moves I didn't spend a lot of time
actually on all these moves because it's
a fairly short time control game in 70
minutes and I knew if I play good solid
moves I'm not gonna be worse whereas my
opponent actually started to use quite a
lot of time you know he was he was
thinking perhaps you know it's like
I I can't speak for him but I imagine he
was looking at some of the more critical
lines where you know this Bishop comes
out to be 5 with cheque or maybe I I go
for all my pawns in the center right
away he had to work on these critical
lines whereas if I just play solid good
moves I know my positions gonna be fine
whereas my opponent maybe was a little
bit not not so much expecting this exact
position to occur yeah so Ryan just just
said for the YouTube crowd this is the
first Pannonia he had ever played so
perhaps he was a bit unprepared for this
type of position but ok the game
continued he actually played east six
here I play a simple improving move
Knight c4 and now he plays Queen e7
which looks like a strange move but it
makes a little bit of sense when you
realize how difficult blacks position
actually is you would love to develop
this Knight right you would love to
vault this Knight to d7
but the problem is d6 hangs so you can't
do that
maybe you could bring this night to a a
7 or a 6 rather and come back to c7 or
up to b4 but like I said with this pawn
here the knight doesn't have so many
prospects on b4 because it its natural
follow-up is to come into d3 or c2
somehow and that's just not gonna happen
y can just develop normally and put a
lot of pressure on this pawn so my
opponent plays queen e7 perhaps
preparing d8 if necessary you can even
defend this pawn with something like
ninety eight if he really really has to
this move also makes it threat if I were
to just develop something like takes
would now cause some problems for me
along this this file for example a line
like this might happen and while I
haven't lost any material yet I didn't
really think exchanging all these pawns
in the center was best for me so I have
a few options here I can try to play a
highly tactical line like Bishop f4
where I'm eating eat XD with Bishop
takes d6 I can move the Queen out of the
way I can bring my rook to the e-file
and allow a queen trade but activate my
Brook in the process or I don't know if
you come up with some other idea you can
let me let me know that but which of
these options do you think is the best
moving the Queen out of the way they're
like d3 or f3 playing more tactically
with Bishop f4 or bringing the knight
the rook to e1 which of these do you
guys like
any ideas
sure so you want to activate this bishop
as quickly as possible like I said
trying to use some tactics here so
you're not solving this problem just yet
but you are developing with another
threat and this is a perfectly fine way
to play in fact this is I think the
computers top choice for white however
in the game I was starting to develop a
nice time edge and I looked at me was
like Bishop f4 but I decided why not
just play simply you know my position
seems good my opponent's pieces are a
little bit disc oriented I'm just gonna
keep things simple he made a threat I'll
respond to the threat and you just kind
of hold the position and I think this is
a really nice practical idea instead of
going for all these complications where
I have to calculate very accurately if I
miss something you know something might
go wrong for me I just play Queen f3
moving my queen out of the threat that's
not to say Bishop f4 is the wrong idea
in fact it I think it is the best move
but practically I like this move Queen
f3 just stepping out of the way my
opponent responds with Knight F to d7
aiming to trade off some pieces once
again I just play simply Queen g3
stepping out of the threat of the knight
preemptively he continues with 95 and
now I have a few options do you think I
should capture this Knight do you think
I should move out of the way or oh yeah
I can't come up with a third option
capture the knight or move out of the
way what do you guys think
move out of the way so why is that
yeah that's that's true he gains some
time here with bishop takes e5 hitting
the queen so are there any fans of
Maurice Ashley in the audience
any Maurice Ashley fans yeah Bishop g5
might be a playable move you might run
into some stuff like f6 just bring it
back well lookout your nuts hanging yeah
so any fans of Maurice Ashley Jason kind
of he has a saying about captures which
I guess you guys might not know
he says if it's not forced or fantastic
don't don't do it is the PG way that
phrase ends so Knight takes e5 is not
forced it's not fantastic in fact it
kind of helps my opponent here he has
less space in the center so the more
pieces we trade off the less that space
advantage really makes a difference if
you'll notice he doesn't really have
enough squares to put these two knights
on and if I take one off the board then
his test becomes a little bit easier so
I just play Knight e3 yeah it improves
his bishop as well so 93 we run in
tonight a six he finally does develop
and now it was kind of decision time for
me I know more or less what my opponents
gonna do he wants to come back to c7
eventually open up this this file maybe
eventually he even wants to play move
like f5 really breaking down my center
pawns you can also you know improve the
rook slowly
I don't know bringing the rooks maybe do
these squares maybe do these squares
this is what my opponents gonna do so I
had to decide do I want to open things
up now or do I want to try to improve my
pieces before I open things up this is
the tough decision to make when is the
right time to open it up so let me give
you a couple options first of all what
is the way white is going to eventually
open things up with a common plan
yet start with f4 and then where do you
go from f4 what's the next pawn break
yeah Felix so E 5 is a common one but
there's actually one more which is a
little bit more relevant here than a 5
any ideas so this H pawn move that
sometimes this comes into play that's
not what I'm thinking here I'm actually
considering this move f4 to f5 it
actually is kind of the most
controversial meaning it creates the
most tension in the position it's
challenging all of Blacks LightSquared
pawns and really forcing the issue and
so now let me give you a couple options
we have an idea of what the the plan is
going to be one option is to play f4 f5
immediately saying now is the time to
open it up or another option is to
slowly improve your pieces play a move
like King h1 stepping off this diagonal
if your play moves like Bishop d2 rook
e1 and play more slowly like this so
which one would you - would you guys
prefer between these two f4 f5
immediately or the slower approach just
improve your position say I can improve
my pieces more than your opponent's
pieces yeah slower approach
kind of behind them vote okay fair
enough
all right look yeah that's that's fair
enough let's take a show of hands who
votes for the slower approach okay
got about half the room who votes for
the faster approach all right the other
half of the room pretty much so this is
the main thing that I consider at least
when considering this choice the
question is who can make better use of
the extra time do my pieces improve more
with the extra time or do my opponent's
pieces improve more with the extra time
so I was thinking about it you know I
can play this move King age one my
opponent will improve this Knight to c7
maybe I do play this line that I
mentioned with Bishop d2 and I thought
now if I'm taking such a slow approach
perhaps my opponent will actually start
doing things perhaps this move he takes
d5 will come perhaps this move f5 will
actually come and if I'm not careful
let's say I don't really think I can
take because of this idea although I
don't know maybe maybe ninety five is
working here it's complicated but takes
even just takes takes takes you know all
of a sudden things are opening up my
opponents making some threats in the
center and I decided I didn't really
have enough time to play the slow way
otherwise my opponent was gonna start
doing things actively and while white
still might be doing fine here I kind of
wanted to play the game on my terms
I wanted to force my opponent to respond
to my threats and that has a huge value
practically psychologically as well as
just even objectively the best moves if
you're playing your plan and your
opponent has to respond to it then it's
very easy for them to get on the
backfoot
start playing passive moves start trying
to defense and missing their own ideas
so for that reason I decided this
Knights sidelined on a six this rooks
still out of the game over here the
fastest way for me to improve my pieces
is to do things like bringing this
Knight to g4 and the bishop out
immediately so to do that I'm going to
break through and then try to a
immediately did you have a question yet
92 this is also possible yet to f4 yeah
this would be another way to improve but
it's it's that same problem where I
thought black could make better use of
the time than me I thought black if I
took things too slowly he was going to
break through before me
yeah that's not to say 92 is a bad move
I think it's a perfectly fine move
perfectly playable but it's this
difference in styles of playing I liked
opening it up immediately
so I played f4 97 and f5 my opponent has
a lot of options here
in fact I didn't really calculate all of
them through to the end I just knew that
okay I'm making a lot of threats on
these puns probably he's going to have
to break the tension pretty quickly he
can try something like Bishop e5 I'll
move my queen out of the way but all of
a sudden yeah there's a lot of problems
in the game my opponent chose to do a
takes f5 and once again the nice thing
about playing the break for yourself is
that you're kind of forcing the choices
onto your opponent saying how are you
going to deal with this show me and so
he had to make a choice he chose he
takes f5 I captured and then the move he
came up with was simply Knight c7 so now
we see really this idea where my
opponent needed that extra time more
than I did he had to play an entire
tempo in a critical position just to
improve his piece whereas it would be a
lot easier for him to play this move if
I hadn't already ripped things open and
was making so many threats on the Kings
side so this is the advantage to opening
things up faster
now with this Knight gone from a5 I have
this very nice move Knight g4 and taking
advantage of the fact that he no one no
longer controls that square and I'm
actually opposing quite a difficult
problem to my opponent if once again he
takes more time to improve his pieces my
threat is actually to play f6 and this
would win the game essentially
if you play night tix I'll play Bishop
g5 and this pin is too much and if you
play Bishop takes I will capture first
and then once again Bishop g5 will come
and this will just be winning so to
solve this problem
my opponent tried h5 trying to kick this
night away
removing my threats on on f6 yeah
question what are we talking about 9 h5
here
so tactically this this doesn't really
work out I can take here this Knights
attacks this Knights attacks
yeah it's important to calculate though
and so we are running a bit over time
here so I'll try to keep this quick so
after h5 up until this point I have been
calculating quite a lot of moves but I
haven't really been seeing them through
to the end after h5 this is really the
critical moment this is where you have
to double down really think about your
move try to find the best line calculate
the line through to the ends and try to
find the tactical way to either win the
game or improve your position the most
or at least you know keep your ideas
going so after h5 there are a lot of
things you have to calculate we don't
have time to go through everything the
best move is actually Knight h6 when in
fact after King h7 rook e1 there is this
Knight takes f7 move and actually missed
this in the game but this would have
been a very nice way to finish it off in
the game I chose a different line with
Bishop f4 not removing this Knight from
it's very nice position of course it
would be pretty bad for white to just
retreat back and kind of admit okay I
was wrong h5 was a good move
so I played Bishop f4 I expected him to
take when I would take on d6 and hit
both the knight in the queen this is the
tactical justification of it and then I
would just kind of play from there
instead my opponent actually tried 95
and I don't think this move is is very
good and allows me to play the move I've
been wanting to play this whole time
which is yes f6 that's totally right
and after f6 hitting both of these
pieces he has to take and the advantage
of leaving my knight here is now pretty
clear I get to capture back and there
are a few ways white can win here Bishop
g5 followed by Bishop e7 is nice
I chose Bishop h6 just hitting the Queen
and the rook my opponent played Queen h8
I just took the material and brought my
knight in and the problem isn't just the
exchange it's all of these dark squared
weaknesses from my opponent and the rest
of the game was was kind of trivial from
there
my opponent Ryan was was very low on
time and so some blenders happens just
Knight takes d5 Rick ad 1h for a little
Intermezzo just move my queen out of the
way the night before rook takes d6 and
after Knight takes c2 who sees the final
tactic to end again this one's not too
hard
anybody
Tim
no Felix Knight f6 check you got it King
g7 and you just pick up this night for
free yeah yeah Burke takes f7
interesting idea is to look for there
but this one's a bit simpler than that
you just take the knight into your my
opponent resigns so those were two of
the biggest games that really decided my
rating after these two events and
fortunately for me ended up over 2200 so
it's on to the next goal for me any
questions about either in the games I
went over today or any of the ideas we
talked about and your buddy alright
thank you for the applause with that of
Mines that is all from me tonight thank
you guys very much for joining me
be sure to stick around I stole a bit of
his time but Ryan Deering the victim of
this game will be teaching the endgame
class directly after this until then
I'll see you next time on the road to
2000
you